yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing IM Hawksmoor who's that Dean
hair got interesting never play them ok
so let's go for this huh seems to be
popular somehow and exactly why to do
know exactly why I mean I'm not saying
it's bad just I got this like for the
second time now and very short order
night h6 is funny this Quincy one it
seen this happen ok maybe here and not
all the way back yeah that's probably
not fantastic for black but at least
I've gotten an IQ p position where I've
got fianchetto that's not so bad will be
three okay what are you doing there with
your queen 9635 no doesn't look so
dangerous these fires like this one okay
so i would to start between before could
be something let's do it and ask him
about the Queen I'm not sure that he
likes me to take them
hmm ok I'm thinking this should be okay
maybe not six Wow oh ok opening up ok oh
I'm take it anyway I have to take it
yeah I have 95 though maybe no 393
weapon sounds like but anyway this is
this is not bad I don't don't don't
think so there should be six attacking
the pawn on yep that it cannot be a bad
move very unlikely at least what is he
doing now looped you Mon may be
attacking this no going back let's
activate let's activate stuff attacking
on c3 now and we'll see one I can take
and play in either too ok so this one
and now i'm attacking be too just for
not much probably let's see for maybe
try and show no pressure checks other
Bishop c4 okay um well catia can take be
two with our like you can also click
here Knight takes and then like 85
maybe it makes sense to push this back
first and go from there the bishop only
three is not ideally placed simply
because after any Bishop takes Knight
eggs I'm able to take so like it takes
90 x 90 I'll take you three well it
doesn't really help all that much anyway
taking a ball on the two shouldn't be
terrible then maybe still just take some
classified sir form
and that's before not know okay I still
has not stood for some are on the radar
yeah maybe it meant room to put up the
lane move this one but if I go Bishop g7
it takes nice to form okay now maybe
just special III now maybe
so the size is going to go to be six
okay I see it I see the point I can't
have many let's keep it ever be sure
defaults certainly okay can this is that
okay I can play no doesn't help
still like T 596 here
yeah not easy m to a position five is
not good kind of sucks here I mean I can
call night c8 but just looks quite
ridiculous time morning here I can
promise anyway we'll see
okay get it to me for I mean ok I
understand that this is a good Bishop
it's still not only for should do also
should do some things
Group D 194 for example would be pretty
pretty bad okay Bishop before you can
play but still
as well as P awkward ok
playing for 93 here it's pretty nice the
Arabian mate let's see how I defense
against this I'm quite sure what what is
Morris decided not to react at all my
night still has no it doesn't have many
squares like what I think I get to
evacuate it and eventually okay so yeah
I know that foolish didn't get to get
enough out of this somehow it was a
decent position here I think yeah I
clean before i'm unsure about but it
felt right be five ticks ticks here so
yeah and from here I think maybe room
for improvement for white plate this 94
can make sense you know this is this
looks like something yeah the engine
agrees light each was a bit of a passive
looking move maybe 94 in fact this is
what the computer gift is stuck with
this pawn em but we should pair some
good activity 45 coming down
now small extra black seems fair with
their ninjas yeah here it gets it gets
nice well night takes was not strong
with it so that that surprises me really
[Music]
really oh good I therefore would notice
ok it doesn't have squares I seem so
okay so night takes was actually better
ok 8 and then I just decided to to take
it yeah probably something here ok so i
should go 85 in fact how no i didn't see
this correctly so here i have this move
and then march my own deep on and that
in fact looks good yeah this is a pain
though the f-bomb cannot move and here
my pieces look very good now that's very
strong this engine suggestion ok 98 yes
I at least I'm not we'll see i will tell
sure we'll see 8 okay see I was playing
for this amazing idea maybe that was
wrong but it looked it looked
interesting so the engines are ok ok ok
ok so the thing is yeah that here if he
takes this is coming with still
name yes that wins so he cannot actually
take their don't have to go with with
further checks can't do so don't quite
understand the entrance line so the deep
part isn't that dangerous so f53 and
okay like I only get to win the bishop
for the porn and then it's a draw yeah
okay what was interesting try at the end
ok guys thanks for watching